so i want to know were you familiar with
the book before signing on to this i
know some people had to read it in
school
and some people just know the title but
haven't actually read the book
yeah i was one of those guys i felt
embarrassed because i did like
english literature at university i i
never read it i mean i knew
where the title was from i knew it was a
bit like 1984. i didn't know about soma
and the bureau of stability and stuff at
all i didn't actually read it until i
got the part in um yeah a bit
embarrassing
not that embarrassing no i feel like
it's just one of those books you know
the title of but not if you weren't
forced to read it
in school which was cool you know um so
then
once you did read it what do you love or
find fascinating about this story
well in terms of reading the book i was
just amazed at a guy in 1932
what he predicted and the way the world
was going bear in mind what had not
happened in 1932
which shapes our world um so much today
he he foresaw this society of
first of all in need of constant
stimulation to remain happy and constant
distraction
and everything is designed to avoid
anxiety
and to make sure that you never get in
that moment where you're just sitting on
your own for five seconds and you start
thinking everything is designed to stop
that
and i recognize that i mean i feel you
know i sit down for five seconds and
i don't have my phone on me it's a
moment where i wonder what to do do i
mean
it's oh yeah and that was close to a
hundred years ago now he was already
there
and david weiner the showrunner and the
other amazing writers
have taken definitely the philosophy and
the rules of the world that he created
and woven and expanded ultimately
um a new more kind of character led
an emotional emotionally driven
epic uh narrative from a very
short book which ultimately is almost a
kind of an essay you know a parable
almost an allegory
um so but the two together uh it's very
interesting that similarities and
differences
yeah your character is so curious about
the world outside of the society that he
lives in what was it like for you
kind of getting into the mindset of
bernardin what is it about him that
makes him so curious
well the weird thing is that bernard
shouldn't be curious no one's curious
everyone's happy what's the problem
you're an alpha class you're a counselor
you're going to give out these drugs to
anyone who needs them and
so why has he fallen off the wagon why
is he spending time offline why isn't he
even having enough sex
is it for us it's very relatable it's
natural human anxiety he's just somewhat
clumsy vulnerable person yeah but yeah
him and lenina and c jack joseph
morgan's
character they all start to feel the
same thing and is it
the same thing that they're feeling when
they don't have a word for it is it to
do with john's
um soon arrival uh these are the
questions that were being asked at the
beginning
um i love a good sci-fi show i mean
sci-fi the genre in general i'm just
you know i've loved for years but what
do you think it is about this show that
will appeal to everyone i think
it's very i think this show is relatable
to everyone and it's for everyone
because there are many different factors
of both the society and the story uh
that will
speak to you i find still just thinking
about what to say to these
uh interviews and watching a couple
episodes again there's so much you can
say about it about what is
how this society is much like our own
how we could end up like that would we
want to end up like that
how do you cut out pain and if you do
can you really be happy
but the story and could these questions
ask on a huge grand
beautiful scale i thought the music and
the costumes and just production is
epic and beautiful and designed to make
you feel good
yeah the story's gonna pick it up yeah
well you know the episodes just as
you're saying you're talking about it
being epic they're so beautiful what was
it like being on set
well i mean it was mad we feel so many
sets
yeah and i ran out of space within kind
of weeks there were
tiny bits of sets all plugged in next to
each other i remember filming in my
burner's apartment for the first time
the smell of paint like that literally
they were
moments before action they were still
touching it up it was fast
and the designer david is uh
extraordinary man he takes his
influences from all over the world
and these societies that were designed
by ai ultimately
and so the design of the whole city uh
it's all
very cleverly designed the interior's
next theory is to come together and give
you an idea of what the society is and
how it works
and mainly it's just like it's meant to
be stunning yeah
um demi moore is obviously a legend um
and she looks so great with her
different hair
and you know she has a whole new look
going on what was it like working with
her
i was really fun she's so down to earth
and easy and just how you wanted to be
i i got on with her uh great because uh
she has loads of dogs at home and she
missed her dogs and i had my dog with me
all the time
um i've got a tiny little poncho called
zoe and she
to me kind of adopted him i just come
back
[Music]
okay now this this might be i don't know
if this is the right way to phrase it
but in terms of a brave new world if if
all of a sudden that became our society
today what would you choose
the the happiness or would you want your
freedom
yeah the happiness of food in question
is one like the heart of this
in some ways
there are definitely days when i'm you
know father of a one-year-old in a busy
crazy household i would definitely take
a summer pill and
yeah tap out for sure uh but i think the
idea that you can't be on your own and
you're not allowed to think for yourself
and you don't even have the tools to be
able to do that
but you will probably still have this
itch the itch of humanity and
insecurity and not being able to do
anything with that i think would be
ultimately
really uh difficult uh so i think i'd
enjoy it for a bit
nice um it was so nice talking to you
congrats on the show
thanks morgan cheers yeah i'll see you
later
you